[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is your heart
[Music]
rivers
[Music]
you
[Music]
down down by the river
[Music]
is
[Music]
down
[Music]
don't wake me up just
let me show you what's to come
your enemies will fall
the realms will tremble with the change
you bring
you'll have everything you could ever
desire
hello everybody and welcome to panel
from hell
number two i'm so happy to be here with
you today and i hope you
last time we did this it was a lot of
fun and i think we are going to have a
lot of fun today also
obviously we're going to be talking a
lot about update 4 patch 4 as we call it
for baldur's gate 3. we have a full
program about it
we're going to be talking to david
walgrave or head of production about the
contents of patch 4.
we'll be talking about the patch also
with jeremy crawford from dungeons and
dragons the principal rules designers
over there
and with our own nick buchanan who is
going to explain to us
how we did a certain thing that i'm not
gonna announce just yet
uh we will also have some non-ballast
gates reviews we're gonna be talking
about our board game the divinity
originals in two
kickstarted board game that is we'll
chat about some
important to use news which is important
for us and
uh we will top it all off with a live
gameplay
uh featuring the very big thing that
we're announcing today that contains
many things but which i'm not allowed to
name and for which we have no other name
than the very big thing that contains
many other things
now before we get started uh it would be
good to put our campaign into
perspective
to see where we are in our early access
campaign
and chat about uh everything that's
happened so far and
everything that's going to come we
launched early access
a little over four months ago a little
over four months ago sorry
on october 6th and since then we
released
i think it's three updates and six hot
fixes
and those were presented uh give or take
a few about 15 000 change lists as we
like to call them and patch 4 which is
releasing today
actually contains another 15 of those 15
000 of those change lists
and that means that this patch is as big
as everything else
that we've uh done uh before together
so what can you expect well let's maybe
talk first about things that we did when
we
started out with uh patch four uh sorry
with uh baltic gate three on early
access
uh our initial focus was on increasing
stability increasing performance
getting fixed actually work and then
gradually we started
uh plugging in things that were
reactions to community feedback that
we're receiving
um we for instance we changed the way
that gun trips worked uh you guys
weren't big fans of all the surfaces
that we created at the country so we
removed those
uh we changed the way that wrestling was
working we changed
approval ratings so there there was
quite a lot of
upset about uh how intolerant some of
our party members were so we tweaked
that a little bit make them a bit more
tolerant
and like this we added a whole bunch of
uh
things we focused on quality of life
so for instance we made it so that if
you jump over a
uh obstacle uh then the rest of the
party will also jump over it so he
didn't have to micromanage them
uh we put in an upcasting ui so that uh
changing
the level at which you're gonna cast the
spell was gonna become easy
we introduced rewards for peaceful
solutions to
certain confrontations that you had in
the game we added also features like
inspiration points or cross saves we put
in
extra tutorial messages we improved the
combat ai so we added a whole ton of
things
and a lot of these things were literally
inspired by the feedback that we got
on the forums on the community channels
but also from the analytics that you've
been sending us
and that we've been using to tweak
pretty much everything
in the game and that's exactly how it
should be this is how early access works
uh as you play the game we get the data
that we need to
improve it we keep on releasing updates
like the one that we're
going to reach in the very near future
not today not today but in very near
future
and at the same time we also continue
working
on the actual game which one day is
going to materialize but
we still have a lot of work obviously so
with all of that
uh we're gonna go start and chat with uh
david
uh head on production he is going to
explain to us uh
everything that's in patch four except
one big thing but we'll chat about that
later too so let's move on head over to
david
i'm gonna take my little screen here and
try not to fall
in my very flexible but just not suited
armor and we'll head over
it all right to the campsite
hello david is he meeting you here hello
it's uh
it's the video is it what it's davidian
it's my people name
oh sorry the video i'm sorry i'm not
gonna call you david anymore
and so uh our proof campsite here
um hi hi how are you
how's it going i'm i'm i'm fine i'm a
happy camper and i can
all right i just said that so you could
make that joke yeah thank you thank you
all right so
uh we've been chatting before uh we
started on this panel
and so you lost a dice roll yeah and so
as a result
you're not allowed to talk about a very
big thing that contains many things but
you're like about talk about
every single thing that is not the very
big thing in patch 4.
so tell us what's new so i did lose the
dice roll
so i cannot talk about the thing with
all the other big things
but i have another big thing and that's
like every other
change that we did apart from the big
thing because apart from the big thing
there's an entire team working on lots
and lots of stuff
so let's talk about that too shall we i
can i can keep on going yes
okay so ahead start start the first
thing i want to talk about speaking of
dice rolls is
we're introducing loaded dice what is a
loaded dice what is a loaded dice so
um if you're playing tabletop right uh
throwing in natural one once in a while
is just funny
i can see that is a
natural one yeah so if this happens your
friends are going to make fun of you and
everyone's laughing
but if it happens okay it won't be a one
again
really it will because i pressed the one
ah
then stop pressing the one anyway if
this keeps on happening in a video game
you get frustrated
because the thing in the user interface
percent chance to hit if you missed two
times
three times or three times you stop
believing that and you get frustrated
uh so we now introduced an option it is
an option
where you can turn on loaded dice and
that is going to start
turning luck your way okay
so it's going to give you a little extra
it's really going badly and then it's
going to give you like for instance
something like this right
it's it's already better so what it does
is
it just remembers that you got at least
once and an 85 percent chance
to hit and it's not going to do that
probably
if there's still a bit of it's probably
not going to do that the next time
so uh what else did we do on the dice we
had a loaded dice
do you remember the speak of the death
spell of course you do
yeah i do it so uh go to a fallback
position actually so we make
a possible game to kill pretty much
every single protagonist
and so
there's a problem with my microphone
apparently
all right
yeah wait yeah all right
we're going to attack him
whispering
see this is exactly what happens when
you roll too many once things like this
start happening
so uh my mic broke and so we're now
using a boom mic so this thing floating
in the air
and hopefully it's gonna pick up all of
our voice so we were talking about speak
with to that
speak with that microphone for instance
would not be a good thing to do
but uh speak with that tell me what did
we do so
uh we already had the spell and we
already had dialogues on on corpses that
you could talk to obviously
yeah uh but we improved it so
first of all the highlight was improved
so you can very
easily spot the courses that you can
talk to
but that's not all we wrote extra
dialogues for
speak with the day corpses that were not
there before but that's not all
uh we gave them sound effects so that
they really sound gruesome that they
really sound like a corpse and then we
added vfx on top of that
and as if that was not enough we are
making cutscenes or we have made
cutscenes for all of the speak with the
dead uh
okay that we have so that was something
that would still work in progress when
we also in early access and now you
actually have the cinematics that go
with it
all right good uh can you remind people
how speak with that works
like what it is when you cast a spell
and there's a spoiler in there somewhere
it's easy to get
uh even at level one but i won't say how
if you do cast a spell
you see all the corpses that have
something to say actually light up
yeah and then you can ask them questions
they do need to have a mouth right yeah
so they do need to have a mouth
otherwise they cannot
pronounce the words and then you get a
couple of you got a limited couple of
questions that you can ask them yeah
and then when we started making the game
actually at some point we were
thinking about how we're going to
implement it and so the initial idea was
actually to decapitate
everybody so that we wouldn't have to do
it because yeah it would also have been
pretty cheap so
we just did it across the board for many
many npcs not all nbc's though
the ones that don't highlight they don't
have to speak with that schematic right
no okay you couldn't do every one
because not everyone has something
interesting to say
that well that's a value adjustment
there
in real life anyway so if you
uh go further what else do you have on
yourself oh speaking of cinematics uh
we kept on improving cinematics we had
to speak with the dead and we said why
not everything
so it started with lighting uh we have
someone working on lighting and just
changing lighting and settings of
lighting can can completely change
the atmosphere of uh i think we have a
video of that
is that playing yeah there it goes so
you see basically the before and after
here
of what it looks like when the lighting
team has gone over something and it
really makes it does make a big
difference
but it didn't end there because while
while they were at it uh they
animated uh animals that appeared
better they changed camera angles they
changed positions like they just
improved cutscenes they
even made cutscenes where there were no
cutscenes before
did you know that there's about 25 000
cinematic notes like this
in the early access version uh yeah i
looked down that number
i mean this is just the act one content
right so there's still all the other
stuff that we're making that is being
done
yeah no it is vastly insane
uh okay so what else do you have well
so i have a list right because you said
you you can you can talk about
everything but
another thing i like the way you you got
your list also i'm standing here like
with high tech and you're
uh i like your way more i have to say
it's it's a list
so one of the things that i write wrote
down here is you can
use a torch a lot easier right now
what's wrong with the old way of using
it
the old way of using a torch was really
a hassle you had to click probably 12
times before you finally had a torch in
your hand i did that on the previous
panel
and so i needed to cross the fire
surface but with my cancer which i can't
do anymore because they removed the
surfaces from cancer so now i needed to
lift a torch
well then i had a horse or maybe a
candle anyway i needed a source of fire
right and i need to put a source of fire
on stores of fire to put my torch in
and then i was i had to equip my torch
then
all right this is the thing yeah so
right now if you find the torch you
click it
to pick it up it picks up and it
automatically adds a torch icon to your
hotbar
if you click on that torch icon on your
hog bar it swaps your weapon
immediately and it lights up immediately
if you click the button again
it equips the torch and re-equips the
weapon that you have alright that's
that's what one would call a quality of
life improvement is there a flint
actually
well there's let's say there's a hidden
flint because you can automatically
secret flint yeah
you remember flint from dragon band i do
okay good
uh what else do you have um you can now
target portraits why would you want to
target portrait
uh
magic spells and when you click on the
button you used to have to
find the character that you wanted to
heal or blast or curse or whatever you
can now just
click a party portrait and use your
interface all right that's what i mean
by you can target all right so that
sounds like a basic necessity of life
that's
added so we added that impact okay good
good
what else we improved multiplayer a lot
so i i'm sure no a lot of people who are
going to be happy about that
and we keep on improving multiplayer so
we're working on making the connection
more stable uh
finding a party more easier uh you can
actually see each other's inventories
and stats right now in multiplayer yeah
so you can steal each other you sell the
[ __ ] right
or talk to each other like what do you
need to yes yes
because you're playing with your friends
oh that's good actually it's like it's
nice to be able to strategize and tell
the other player like do this do that do
that
and then the other player obviously
listens obviously i always do
all right speaking of listening we added
the fleeing mechanic
okay like if it's not going your way you
have a safe distance from the enemy we
added a fleet button you can now flee
from combat so that you don't die every
time that you know like we're not gonna
make them okay and so
is it like the party that can flee or so
if i press the fleet button we all flee
when we're playing together or
no it's individual so i flee and i
abandon you completely well i mean
i you tactically retreat yourself to
regroup and think and strategize on how
you're going to come and resurrect your
body right yes resurrect my body
yeah sure so when you flee i i think
it's you you go to camp then when you
flee
yeah yeah okay good all right that's so
that's cool i like that
you have more uh yeah um oh patch four
is going
to be the last really big batch because
i mean
i just told people there were going to
be many more i mean a big download
uh every patch that we do even if it's a
tiny hotfix you have to download
dozens and dozens of gigabytes and we're
looking into that system we looked into
that system we improved it so from now
on all of the subsequent patches
are going to be smaller okay so didn't
you announce that
once before you did yeah
and we we keep on improving the system
you didn't ship the system last time so
now you're you're good to ship it you're
sure
yeah yeah now what happened last time
ducky was that now it works guys please
didn't they say it worked last time no
so why did we announce it i don't know
okay so i guess something happened as we
were doing it anyway
uh all right so you don't need to go to
your internet provider anymore
bank them from some extra gigabytes like
after you downloaded a baltic gate 3
patch
except this one last time yeah we did it
last time we don't know yet
what the size will be yeah because we're
still like doing the final tweaks to it
and
it's still in qa right now right yeah
but it's nearly right it's nearly ready
all right so what else do you have i
have lots and lots and i won't list them
all the list is long enough lots and
lots of user interface improvements
we re-skinned all of them i think no
they don't just
not all of them no re-skin they just
look better
one really big one that you'll notice is
the options ui
um it's it's completely different nobody
goes to the options ui
people do we have another ui that you
can talk about change video uh
the the container interface
yeah so what changed uh you can sort now
on uh on value or a name
all right and there was also another
button in there so that you can now
access your account basically access
your inventory that opens up in a time
well in a window on screen so that you
can drag items in between i think i'll
show that on my on my live stream that
will
make it clear all right so what else uh
what else where are we okay we improved
pathfinding
again but we can keep on improving
pathfinding
this time around other characters and
more specifically around the village
mill
you will improve the pathway
specifically around the village mill
the community said you cannot find your
path around the village middle
right okay i guess we're going to blame
edgar again right uh we have
been doing so for the last 10 years yeah
we probably don't use
any of his code anymore but yeah edgar
was
our very very good gameplay programmer
who is still with us
today and uh we've been annoying him
forever not because he was the one that
started on the pathfinding
on day one i mean like and it's not a
simple problem that
and he doesn't have anything to do with
it anymore to be fair also yeah so
it's not fair to blame him i'm sure he
wants to i think so too i think he likes
it
so we'll just keep on doing it all right
what else do you have um
get have proper gift weapons good for
the gift i would say yes yes
maybe goodbye you can grab one that's
why you care
ah because i can steal them from the
game you're good okay it's pretty hard
fight okay fair enough okay what else do
you have
uh the flaming fists now have a shield
with
their coat of arms on it let me guess
it's an important detail it's an
it's a fist how did you know is it yeah
i actually didn't check so i don't know
what it is all right okay all right all
right
so do you have anything else but
cosmetic things i mean because you're
going on cosmetic things here i know you
want to talk about the big thing but you
can't
so what else do you have um if you have
a condition in combat
you can now go to the combat log and
mouse over that condition to get more
information about okay so this is cool
because
like understanding what's happening
under the hood is important and this is
part of
a an entire list of things that we're
going to be doing to make it
that clear to players okay what just
happened if there was a complete
interchange
or interaction of rules yeah so we are
gradually improving feedback and all of
the rules etcetera
okay one okay good what else do you ask
so you're interested
we're gonna have to start accelerating a
bit then but uh okay um
but what are you doing well i started
printing this list before you came and i
stopped because it's a huge racket
obviously
but um i'm not gonna get there and i'm
gonna keep on printing
so uh if you're interested in that type
of stuff uh
the players can now disable tracks by
double clicking on them if they have a
track disarm toothpick
that's handy it's probably from the same
guy that did the torches
yeah well sure uh we removed bonus
action points from herds and mushrooms
so you can now just
eat them without uh having to pay for it
we've turned the double side to 24
meters to max superior dark vision the
devil will be happy
yeah the stinking cloud no longer
affects items and
why would it yeah metal doors are no
longer vulnerable to slashing damage
okay
you can apply multiple hunters is on
targets i don't know what the plural is
of hunters mark
hellas review can no longer be blocked
by terrain we allow dash to actually
double stack
we remove the cooldown from dash and
disengage
which fault electrifies the surface of
the target if they're standing in the
surface
of course your warlock can no longer use
armor of shadows
if they already have an armor equipped
why would i even try
i don't know players can no longer
summon a companion or familiar on top of
another character you could uh if you
found the ring sun walker's gift
you know that one it now gives you dark
knitting an arcane word now gets two
times the wizard level plus the
intelligence modifier to your temporary
hp
the hook holder can now be silent
silence is a really good
term right now so i'm just gonna get
over there we have
more stuff to talk about so as we just
move over and thank you very much david
for this very clear update
uh i know that you couldn't talk about
what you wanted to talk
we're going to head about actually
now
all right tell me when we have sound
we're
guys
all right good sorry about that now that
my mic is gone i have i'm depending on
the boom
thing following me uh so uh you could
hear
we've done a whole bunch of changes that
have nothing to do with the big thing
that we're announcing today which we'll
do together
with jeremy and nick in just a bit uh
but uh it is a reflection of the amount
of work that goes into bald gate three
this patch lock is
for us has been very large because we
have put a lot of effort
in getting it to you and that's also why
it's a little bit later than we had
originally hoped
um and it reflects the probably the the
biggest challenge that we have with
balls gate 3
this game is very big we wanted to make
it very good
and uh but it's taking a lot more effort
than we originally anticipated when we
started on it
in um 2017 our team consisted of
112 people and we thought that was a
very big number back then
but now we grew to four studios spanning
300 people
and still growing and uh it is just a
a monster that that needs to be fed and
last year we announced that we we had a
studio that we opened in kuala lumpur in
malaysia
and we did this so that we were finally
going to be able to do 24 hours
development which was important for
a developer like us that works on these
very big rpgs because it means now that
if we have somebody in qa
that starts in the morning on monday in
kuala lumpur on testing baldur's gate 3
according to one particular critical
path and he's going to spend 120 hours
on the game
instead of having to spend three weeks
on testing the game
he can now have the results of his
critical path at the end of the week by
passing on his save
games to his colleagues in petersburg
and so forth all the way to his
colleagues in
quebec so that's a big thing and that
allowed us to to accelerate
this incredible massive game as
development
but uh even that wasn't enough uh
the i like to say that every single game
that you make
has a certain language that you need to
learn as a developer and once you
learn the language and you can speak it
the game writes itself
this is the case now for balls gate
three i think our team knows exactly
what they're doing they know exactly
which language to speak to it
unfortunately it happens to be a game
that is based on 40 years of dnd
and so the grammar that it uses and the
vocabulary that it uses is insanely
large
and so we had to adapt to that and so to
do that
uh we started uh knocking on the door of
other teams to
uh assist us to help us with making this
uh monster that is baldur's gateway good
monster but still a monster
and one of the teams that's been helping
us already for a couple of years
is the team at turbulence and i have
here today with us
at the studio head of terminus
turbulence james olsen james can you
hear me
i cannot hear you james and ah i didn't
hear i didn't get that could you repeat
that for me please
i said hello this is guilty calling
all right good i'm happy to hear that
guilford is going so james
we have a uh welcome first to the panel
of hell
uh we have an important announcement to
make today uh i'll let you make it
so today we're announcing that we are
creating a new
and shiny larian studio in guildford
okay this is a a very good thing because
the team that james has
is incredibly experienced and so we'll
talk a bit about that uh in a second
but before we continue james can you
explain i like
people there there must be people out
there like me who are geographically
challenged
so can you explain exactly where
guildford is
so guildford is a town just outside of
london in the southeast of england
and which is now just outside of the eu
okay i noticed on that map there that
you guys pushed the irish a little bit
into the
the atlantic there that that's not very
nice of you but anyway
uh so uh why
would one start a studio in guilford i
mean like what's good about guildford is
it pastries is it
what well guilford is in fact
that's for sure but no well guilford is
in famous for over 30 years
of game development and the town is
filled with
small and large game studios and it has
thousands of talented developers working
there
and the area is also surrounded by
universities and art colleges
that are filled with the next generation
of developers so guildford is a
herb of creativity in game development
in the uk
okay cool can you tell me a little bit
about the team like when we started
working with you
uh we like worked with with half of your
team
and so that was such a pleasurable
experience that we
wanted more hence why we're sitting here
today can you tell me a little bit about
your team
sure so we're a super experienced team
and we counted up recently and we have
over 350 years of professional game
development experience
and we've worked on in big studios and
small studios and across
all the platforms that games are made on
over the last
25 years um we've expanded the team
and so we start out with 10 people and
supporting baldur's gate it's doubled
since we started and most recently
we've expanded our animation expertise
to bring people in from the movie
industry
and we have people who've worked on on
star wars on avengers
and ready player one and even lord of
the rings
all right so there's at least some good
movies that they worked on in there uh
i shouldn't say that value judgment
can't do that uh anyway
uh so you guys have been working on vg3
for some time so what what what parts of
the game did you contribute to
so we've been contributing since the
start of 2019
we've worked on the on the rendering
engine on the ik that's in the game
we worked on the gui we worked on the
gameplay did lots of stuff on and
followed a jump or something like that
and we've worked on all the online
services
that are involved as gates and we've
also spent a lot of time working on the
animation in the cinematics
okay so and so now the plan is we're
going to grow we're going to start
recruiting there
uh and you're going to double the team
that you have right now
yep the plan is to double the team that
we have in guildford and continue
expanding in bringing additional talent
to the studio to help make bothersgate
an amazing success all right super
well we are super happy that you guys
decided to join us you were a pleasure
to work with in the past so i'm sure
you're gonna be a pleasure to work with
in the future
uh your expertise is super valued and we
have uh our hr agency uh not agency or
hr team told us like well if you're
gonna add another studio and we need to
recruit there
you're gonna have to give us a little
help and so they convinced us to
put in a small video during our panel
we're gonna show it to you now as we
prepare for the big reveal of the big
thing that contains many things and that
we couldn't talk about just now
with jeremy and with nick and so in this
video
you're going to see or meet some of the
people that are working
on balls gate 3 and they'll tell you why
it is a cool thing
to work on and why it's cool to work at
larian and should you be a developer
watching
i'd be sure to check out the jobs page
at larry.com we have many openings
and uh we will soon i don't know if
they're on there already i will soon be
putting up the entire guildford
batch all right thank you very much
james we'll cut to the video now and
we're going to get ready
for the big thing that contains many
things revealed
okay microphone detected perfect let's
go
i'm a character artist i'm a senior
cinematic animator i'm a senior animator
the associate lead for cinematic
programming quality assurance engineer
i'm the world building director i'm a
vfx artist i'm a character artist i'm an
animator
i'm a technical artist i'm the community
specialist
i love the atmosphere amazing people on
amazing games
i'm proud to belong to a team that
trusts each other we're passionate
we're driven you get to actually have
creative input
you know we try to build something that
is really from the heart there's always
something new to discover
one big happy team we really try to
really convey
what uh make us love video games there's
really
not anything like larian out there we
all love what we're doing here
every day is like going on a dnd
adventure i think people are really
encouraged to be themselves it's
always something changing always
something going on this is a company
that is making
stuff for nerds by nerds which is great
because i am one
a team feels like a real family and the
culture is just
open to individuality you just try to
create something cool and unique
together
i get to see your memes your fan art
having that spark of creativity flow
and have a hand in that that's really a
fun way to spend your day
my favorite thing has to be watching all
of the origin characters be written
seeing fans interact with it you know
make comics about it
make memes about it just all sorts of
that that community interaction is just
so great to see
if i had to say one best thing about
working on battles gate 3
would probably be working on baldur's
gate 3.
knowing that somehow the work you're
doing is
going to make so many people happy is
amazing
being able to create the world and
convince to people that this is a real
living breathing world through sound
it's got those it's got dragons it's
really cool
the fact that it's one of the best rpgs
on the planet the subject matter is so
interesting the creativity that gets
poured into it
well for me it's really visually very
beautiful
it creates a really rich and varied
experience for the user
working on what's going to be the
greatest rpg of all time
i discovered the world of duncan and
dragon working on pg3
and i don't know why i didn't know that
before that's the best thing ever
make something that people enjoy playing
and that makes them feel something
being able to give them this experience
that they can enjoy
wherever whenever and with whomever they
like that's only something i can be
really proud of
working on boulders gate 3 is huge
i used to play baldur's gate 1-2 with my
brother when i was a little kid
so being part of the development is kind
of like a dream come true
and being able to resurrect such a
beloved franchise for a new generation
feels like an honor well obviously the
fact that i get to see you guys being
horny on main
all day every day
excellence team absolutely fun
family team wizards
adaptable big love team
a dream come true it's pretty awesome
friends
home expressive inspiring
family unconventional team unique
awesome whimsical weird
in a good way truly
chaotic good bold identic
that's a nice fancy one for you it's
been ages googling it perfectionist
fun ambitious true gamers
inspiring joyful creatively fulfilling
entertaining fun dynamic
fearless family irreplaceable masteries
positive
pure culture passionate passion
passionate
passionate passionate passionate
passionate professional passionate
super cali fragilistic expialidocious
you want to be in the video i don't
think this would be good idea to do
outside in winter
i just press the record button with my
nose because i've got
gloves
[Music]
rpg hall of fame baby
yeah so they are an awesome bunch and
you can rest assured they put all of
their passion
into making a vg3 as good as they can
get it so it won't be for lack of
passion
uh that this game is well it will
succeed i mean what am i saying
anyway uh we're gonna move over we're
gonna uh what actually is nick
nick nick can you stop eating the grass
and come over please
nick nick
is he coming nick
i think we lost in the transformation
there what's happening
we lost them
oh there he is okay
you got a camera problem
there you are oh stuff you destroyed the
camera
well it's the mic then it's the magic
what can i say technology and magic
doesn't work together
all right nick very happy to be here we
need jeremy on board also where's jeremy
can we see jeremy
you get him to join
looks like our life
measures jeremy can you hear us jeremy
hi jeremy from seattle hi there
okay i am amazed by your transformation
nick
[Laughter]
yeah he's been working on it very hard
and studying very hard especially
right so uh we are here together to
announce the next big
uh class in baltimore iii and that is uh
the druid
uh of course of course i mean like as if
the cow was not a dead giveaway
so jeremy uh you are the principal rules
designers at dungeon and drugs at
wizards of the coast
at wizards on the coast four dungeons
and dragons i should say probably um
can you explain to us why we're making
such a big deal about
druids so the druid
is one of the classes that has been in
dungeons and dragons going all the way
back to the game's
early days in the 1970s this
class brings together an amazing set
of abilities all themed around the
forces of nature
druids are members of an ancient order
that channels the powers of nature
weather
you know fire and ice lightning
they're able to talk to animals they're
able to heal their friends
by channeling the forces of life that
are around them
and on top of all of this they're able
to become
one with nature by using their wild
shape ability
to transform into animals like the cow
that you just wear nick
druids also on top of all of that
order themselves into these special
orders that are called
circles and so they have specializations
like
all dnd classes do and the two main
specializations for druids are the
circle of the land
and the circle of the moon with the
circle of the land emphasizing
the nature magic of druids and the
circle of the moon
emphasizing that animal transformation
ability
wild shape that all druids share
druids also are really special in dnd
because of their versatility
they have a little bit of everything
they have weapon ability
they've got light armor they have
healing magic they have destructive
magic they can turn into animals
and get around all sorts of problems
that might be a blocker for other
characters
when we designed this class for 5th
edition dnd
and when we designed all of the classes
we had venn diagrams for the classes
and the druid was right at the meeting
point between
the wizard and the cleric and so if you
think of
the versatility and destructive ability
of the wizard combined with
the healing and buffing of the cleric
and then
throw in a dash of nature magic and
animal transformation
you see the wonder that is the druid
class
will say that it's like a classless
class in a class
that sounds familiar yeah it does it
does all right so
nick uh so you were the man in charge
together with your team
of figuring out how we're going to bring
the druid into baldur's gate three
indeed so what did you do like well
maybe you can start with white shade
uh so tell me about wild chicken so
wildshape is of course the the star of a
show
it's the ability of a druid to turn into
a beast and
utilize beast powers
we picked seven forms for you to turn
into
six beasts and one uh
yes currently just for the early access
content to what's your appetite
um such forms as the giant badger
uh that can burrow into the ground
i was about to but it seems like my
magic
panel um oh your magic balance is not
working fine i'm gonna press a button
and i hope
something happens no maybe we should get
that support here maybe we'll we'll
just break out for a second to technical
and uh
so
all right we are back it seems hello
again jeremy
uh we had a windows update so these
things happened
so um okay so we were talking we were
going to see the giant badger
giant badger i believe yeah um so let's
see some giant badger action
this is the multiplayer it looks like oh
yeah oh yeah yeah okay it's a really
good form to sneak around
to bear around um your enemies
locked passages minds that's a teleport
yeah it is it is kind of a teleport and
then you knock down uh and you're
completely wrong you should have done it
behind the guy
you can go through the doors also yeah
oh wow yeah indeed
okay so that's pretty powerful actually
you can really do some some damage
with the badger so you have any other
forms than a badger oh yeah for example
you can turn into
a spider of course arachnophobia alert
warn people with iranophobia that there
is a spider sorry
it's going to be there for two minutes
we will give you a cue when it's gone
i'm sorry
hello nick yeah so you we've uh you will
and you control your enemies with it oh
yeah i remember this we showed this on
the last panel from health
and i had to rush uh to to survive
with that thing that that's actually
cool and you're webbing with it also
yeah you can create webs and other
spiders won't want to attack you
okay so the uh the druid is versatile uh
jeremy uh just mentioned
uh i know that you had a question about
it that popped up during development and
you were afraid to ask him
yes indeed it's an interesting thing but
we're working on these spells and
actions that the druid has
which we're adding about 30. and
something that was interesting about dnd
version of the druid is that
how how comfortable the druid feels with
fire magic so the druid can for example
create a
flaming blade and just burn an enemy to
it
into crisp um so the question would be
jeremy how come
druids are so comfortable with a
destructive element
so that gets to one of those core
elements of the druid of
being so connected to nature that
they're connected not only to the
life-giving aspects of nature
but also to the destructive aspects of
nature
and fire is one of the most destructive
uh forces that you can face in the
natural world
but it's also often a life-giving force
because we know in our world
that a healthy forest often relies on
controlled burns or you know limited
burns for the forest to truly thrive
so druids are tapping into
that force as they do with so many other
natural forces
but there's also a mythological angle to
it
the druid in its early conception in
dungeons and dragons
owed a lot of its identity to various
things that druids do
in irish folklore and one of the things
that druids do occasionally in irish
folklore
is call fire down upon their enemies
and you see this in the tabletop rpg
with druids eventually getting the
firestorm spell
which is actually a direct nod to
uh an event in irish folklore where a
group of druids calls down
a reign of fire on an opposing army
and d often has this sort of thing in it
where
you will you'll see something that's in
the game and you might wonder
how the heck did this get here and often
the answer is
you're looking at something that lodged
in the game from
ancient myth uh in the real world
you've got a little firepower i know
what you're doing don't you have a like
oh yeah
big big ball of fire uh it's a it's a
big one
it's the flaming sphere um
you can control it by the way it creates
a of
a trail of fire and of course it burns
everything and everyone
okay that sounds like the kind of thing
i need
i'm actually i'm actually going to use
this in my life and i figured out a
glitch and i
you gotta promise me if i show you the
glitch that you're not gonna
take it out we'll uh we'll make it a
roll okay
i have a d20 yeah i'm gonna dress your
dice anymore my friend
so hello today what is what is your
favorite thing about the drupnik
i really really enjoy this this little
country they have the thorn whip
uh that you can use to pull off enemies
from high places and oh yeah that's
right
yeah that is actually handy if you can
maybe throw them down
or you fell there how the hell do i get
a bullet on the beach anyway
whoa that's that's a lot of magic that
was uh i think that was somebody
cheating to make that video right
it's very possible all right so uh
there's much more being added like um
one of the things that i thought was uh
like when you
explain it to me is underwhelming is the
good berry and then i'm told that the
goodberry is like a favorite and it's
like considered overpowered is that
correct uh jeremy
so goodberry is loved in the tabletop
game
partly just because of the flavor pun
intended
of this delicious berry that you get to
eat
that not only heals you but also
uh fills you up as if you had just eaten
you know enough food for the day
so there there's just this enchanting uh
narrative component
uh to it it's a bit like lembus bread
from the lord of the rings you know you
you nibble this thing it's like
i'm good on food for the day now in the
tabletop game
good berry can be extremely powerful
if you multi-class so if you are a
druid and you're a cleric who's a cleric
of life
clerics of life are able to boost the
effectiveness of good berry
uh to a level that uh is is
extraordinary
well that's pretty much what qa have
been telling me also
like it's uh it's overpowered gotta go
down on the good berry
and speaking of uh combinations actually
um
we changed the rules uh slightly on how
wild shape works right yes indeed so
we were playing messing around with it
and we thought that it's really cool to
go from one shape to another
in during the combat so we made
dismissing a shape
free and so if you're a druid of a
circle of a moon that
focuses on wild shapes uh you can
dismiss a shape for free and then
use your bonus action to take a new uh
new shape so
that means if i am like my favorite form
uh polar bear
well actually no let's say that i'm a
bird and like which allows me to fly
over large distances like so uh
and then i in the same turn i could turn
my bear
and my birth into a bear is that what
you're saying oh yeah you can fly down
behind the enemies turn into a bear roar
get their attention so you can combo
these forms we have a video of a bear
because it's just
that polar bear is just yeah let's try
the bear
there we go boom
this bear is going to be specific or uh
unique for
moon druids okay all right this is polar
bear so everybody is going to play
circle of the
the moon again look at that guy go i
think we made him uh
be able to sneak as well oh yeah i could
even sneak it just my dog sneaks like
this
he learned it from the cat that's right
it's ridiculous and there he's goading
right so this is like
taking all the aggro to him yeah which
is quite handy actually if you're
walking around with a bunch of puny
mages like i usually do
so jerry jeremy is that okay that we
like change the rules like that for the
white side are you fine with that
for the discussion absolutely
uh so often uh it's
important for people to remember that
designing for
different media requires a different
touch
so designing for the tabletop game is a
very different
beast from designing for a video game
in the tabletop game we constrain
how often a druid can wild shape and how
often you know how rapidly they can
pop in and out of shapes
for two main reasons one in the tabletop
game we want to make sure
play doesn't bog down with too many
different things
happening on a particular turn since
unlike in a video game where the
computer is running the game at the
table top
you know it's all humans who are running
it so we don't want things to slow down
too much
but there's another factor in the
tabletop game
druids can turn into pretty much
any beast they've ever seen as long as
that beast
meets the the criteria listed in the
wild shape feature
that means that as game designers we
don't
actually know what the druids in the
tabletop game are going to turn into
we know broadly what the power of those
animals is going to be
and that's why we've set the challenge
rating limits in the tabletop game
but we don't know the exact animals
they're going to turn into
and so because of the amazing liberty we
provided we had to constrain
how often it could be done uh just so
that we wouldn't create a situation
where druids were not only
transforming constantly but transforming
into potentially game breaking forms
over and over again
and that that is often a theme in our
table top design that if we get really
generous on something that we let you do
as we are
with the shapes that you can turn into
as a druid
we then tend to become much more
limiting
in how often we let you do it so when
you told me that in
baldur's gate 3 some of those
limitations were being lifted it made
total sense to me a
because the computer's running it and b
you know the exact
forms people are going to be turning
into uh
whereas again in the tabletop game we
don't know if the druid is turning into
a dinosaur a mouse
a giant spider or some other fanciful
beast
they've encountered on one of their
tabletop adventures
right we had actually big discussions
about the dinosaur
and because nick wanted to put the
dinosaur and i had to put my foot down
and say we
one day we would like to shift this game
so no dinos
no not even a small dinosaur but
uh when we chatted about this in
preparation for the panel
uh we you said an interesting thing
about utility value of the
druid and wild shape also which is
something i would like to delve in
deeper a little bit because we also
spend a lot of time on
on the game but maybe start with you on
utility and the druid
y-shape yeah one of the things i love
about the druid
not only as a designer but as a player
when i play one
is the amazing utility of wild
shape often people who gravitate to
wild shape particularly if they're
playing circle of the moon
they'll often think of their shapes as
primarily a combat form
but i actually think wildshape's
greatest
value over the course of a campaign is
the many different ways it can break an
adventure
in good ways because often in the
tabletop game we actually
want our players to come up with clever
ways to break things
and wildshape does that in spades
and i love in the video you showed you
showed that exactly
with you know the badger crawling you
know under the wall
uh the you know in a normal circumstance
you might have a group of adventurers
looking at a tower and like oh my gosh
how are we going to get up there and the
druid is just like i'll turn into
a robin fly up there and i'm there
so the druid the druid can create these
amazing
uh sort of unexpected tangents
in how an adventure plays out uh and
and that to me is the most exciting
aspect of wild shape
all right we have a couple of examples
of how we're doing that in the game
because we actually very much
try to make wild shape part of the the
normal gameplay outside of combat
yeah we really want you to stay in your
wild shape while you're exploring and
look for ways to use your wild shape
such as you can turn into a cat yeah
it's international cat day by the way
oh sorry
i'm a dog person well i'm a cat person
so
we have a caterpillar
this is a very aggressive cat but
usually a cat would be sneaking around
as well
um and it can meow to attract um
the attention of the enemies that is
actually pretty cool
i i've used that it's actually pretty
cool just to distract enemies with your
cat
when it's meowing as they do in the
middle of the night right
there's but you can also talk yeah
with animals in the animal so as an
animal uh
you can talk to other animals of course
and and they will sometimes have
specific responses because direct
they recognize you as an animal so here
for example the
player is turning into a polar bear to
get the other bear
a lot improved
i love what the medic did here of course
this added a lot of work for cinematics
okay i did making sure small uh beasts
and
big these lines of dialogue they added
for this patch and cinematic notes as a
result of it also
uh so you can talk to animals uh you can
abuse it well i'll show you how you can
abuse i'm gonna single-handedly do a
dungeon that
has been declared unsingle-handedly
doable with my druid shape
and well i'll try at least so um
there's uh one thing that i've been
meaning to ask you well actually i would
like you to show nick
uh because we just saw that cat was
climbing
but what if i'm like a huge cow with
fire in my eyes i know it's not called
the cow but
i could still think of it it's a deep
broth a mythical
beast from the underdark and of course
you can climb in it because it would be
silly and slow if you would have to pop
in and out of your form every time
all right so that was a big discussion
with the animation team of course
and i love it cracks me up every single
time i see it it's like it's still a
little bit buggy there so that's one of
the things we still need to fix
on the ladder but it's just awesome that
you can do it and indeed i fully
approve of the fact that we don't make
you get out of your regular shape and
then just jump on top of this
and this my bear can also climb like
this so they all can climb all of them
yeah and they can sit also right
they can sit on a chair you just chill
out and maybe you take a screenshot
you can sit on chairs you can lie on
beds and
all kinds of rock slabs that work as bad
in
druid grove all right so this sounds
pretty cool
maybe last bit because you just
mentioned druid groove
balls get three opening act uh you got a
druid groove
yeah and we stand in a druid grove here
right
so um what does that mean for the game
the fact that we added the druid class
well yeah indeed there is big druid
presence in act one and of course they
will recognize you as a druid and you
will have
uh specific responses because you're a
druid and you understand better what is
going on
what kind of conflict they that there
might be uh going on
okay and so you're gonna get extra
reactivity yes you'll you'll get extra
dialogue choices and you will also get
an extra
um storyline uh that ends up with you
becoming the
the warden the faith warden of the group
of warden
yes all right and do you get it like a
fancy stuff uh better than mine actually
yeah what's it called
it's called payload pale oak yes all
right like you know i was talking to
for a member of our team yesterday and i
hadn't realized it was pale oak i
thought it was a polyok
is it polyok i mean very european paleo
okay
all right okay cool uh all right great
well
thank you jeremy for joining us and
seattle uh
i hope you enjoyed our little
interpretation of the druid entire
baldur's gate treat uh thank you nick
well you're gonna be sticking around
with me for the
gameplay demonstration right so i'll see
that you don't break the game
too hard i can i can't no i don't well i
can curse at you as we do that
so um before we are going to jump to our
live gameplay
um we are going to have to set up a
couple of machines over here
and uh as we're doing that we're going
to show you a little video we made
because we don't only make baldur's gate
3 we hope
that he also make divinity original sin
2 and
we started making board games and
graphic novels so we have a graphic
novel which is divinity original sin two
gold woken and it's amazing uh it's got
pictures because it's a graphic novel
that's what graphic novels do they have
pictures i don't know if you can see the
pictures on the screen
so you can get those at uh the shop at
larian.com on the merc store uh if you
read it you will get the origins of the
origin stories
in original sin two so it gives you
extra insight on where they come from
and the board game which is still in
production it was kick-started a bit
over a year ago
is making good progress team is now on
iteration 3
and they made a little video to
basically give you a status update
on where we stand with uh divinity
origin 2
kickstarter and that is presented sorry
that is presented
by none other than our own irish druid
who can put a rain of fire over your
head
kieran kelly
hello everyone it's been just over a
year since we launched the vinnie
originals in the board game on
kickstarter it's really been a year of
changes of improvement and iteration
there's a lot of things to cover and
there's a lot of things to talk about so
let's just jump right in
so the first thing i want to talk about
is actually the artwork for the
locations and the enemies and the bosses
and when you look back at the artwork
that we use for the original kickstarter
while it was good and it was functional
and it did its job it wasn't necessarily
how good we can make it and we knew we
could do better
so a lot of the work this year has been
about iterating on that
changing it reinforcing it making it
better and making a whole lot more
immersive for you
and your party that you're playing and
adventuring with so when you're in a
location like this
it feels alive and it feels like it's
breathing and it's a location that's
worth
journeying in and enjoying as you
adventure through fort joy
[Music]
the second thing we wanted to improve is
actually the miniatures for the game we
got our first
models from a manufacturer and those uh
molds they were really good there was a
lot of detail with them
but actually we realized that we wanted
to make some changes and improve it even
further
and the way we were going to improve
them further was actually not
necessarily the detailing though we
definitely tweaked some of them
it was actually the animation of them a
lot of them were more static they were a
bit more lifeless and statuesque as
opposed to
a living boss that's got a lot of threat
to it that's going to have a lot of
presence on the table
now all the animation all the movement
and the the feeling of movement from
these
from these miniatures are going to make
you feel like these bosses are not only
there and they're present but they're a
threat they're coming to kill you
[Music]
and the third thing to actually talk
about is the amount of play testing that
we've done
obviously during kickstarter we did a
lot of play testing before we did a lot
of internal play testing afterwards
but over this last year we've done a lot
of external play testing we've had two
major play testing groups that have
played through the game
and there's been a huge amount of things
that we've learned through that from
people who haven't necessarily played
divinity to people who play divinity
to people who play a lot of board games
to people who don't a lot of board games
and we're getting a lot of information
that's helped us refine the game and
prove it
and overall just make it a better
experience and more fun experience for
you your friends and your family
so that about does it for how we've been
getting on this year i just want to say
a big thank you to the community for all
the support we've gotten so far
if you're still interested in following
along you can do that on kickstart we do
monthly updates
otherwise you can still back the game on
the larry and merch store
but for me over here fort joy back to
standard of ernest
now how do i get off the signup
all right so that was kieran talking
about originals into the board game
and uh we're ready to start with our
live gameplay presentation it is a live
gameplay presentation
uh things will go wrong i just don't
know which things are going to go wrong
there's one particularly annoying bug in
the game that is the reason why the
patch has not been released yet
that is still being looked for uh in rqa
well there's a few of them actually but
this one is a particularly nasty one uh
so i might encounter it if i encounter
it
uh we will just pretend that we have
technical glitches but
there's good chances that we are not
going to have it and i didn't encounter
it that much many times
but it is there so anyway let me present
you my party
so this is lar it is a um
lightfoot halfling and she is a druid
then we have shadowheart and most people
who played the game in early access
already know
cleric level four also we have a gale
a wizard also a level four and
then we have lyzel my fighter also a
level four
and together we are going to go on a
small adventure
and we are going to deal with a
particularly
nasty lady so let's get in there and get
our quests set up and then from there on
uh we're going to start
showing off all things druitt
get over here and see what this argument
is clapped eyes on your poor sister
drop the act hug you was the last to see
my reina
just let her go please
you there please i don't know what's
come over these boys i
just want to go home stop this
oh my inside
all right so what's going on here
careful don't trust the word out of her
mouth
our sister went to the hug and we ain't
seen her since
hand over heart i don't know their
sister
i will gladly help you all look for her
though enough where
is she um
i could say i won't let you hurt this
woman not getting involved or i could
say like tell the truth what did you do
to their sister so let's go for the last
one
you were supposed to rush to my defense
love
fat lot of good you are some advice
you ever darken my door you'd best have
that head bowed
and an apology at the ready
she could shoot fireworks out of her
backside for all i care
the hug has brina
so will somebody please tell me what's
going on it's our sister
marina she's well
she was in a bad way after her husband
died started saying
weird things like how she was gonna
bring him back
next thing she's gone looking for the
hack with all the stupid things to do
and we haven't seen her since but no
good ever came from dealing with a hack
none of this matters all right we need
to get her back
and fast
well i'm the hero so i'm gonna say let
me i'll bring my arena home
so you can see that i still know that
tolerance of my mistakes
but joel not a chance we're getting her
back on our own now come on
it's a stupid idea boys but have it your
way
all right let's explore these very nice
sunlit wetlands
have a look i mean like how nice and
cozy it is over here
you just want to go and sit on that rock
and just basically
lie down and eat an apple uh i am going
to do something it's
one of those new spells that was added
with update four i'm going to enhance
my abilities and so i can choose between
endurance
or strength for um sorry dexterity
but i'm gonna improve my intelligence i
have a good reason for this i
i rehearsed this thing so i know what's
coming and so this check is gonna aid me
in a check that i'm gonna have to make
so let's go forward
and use my fox's scunning so basically
what's happening now is she's
concentrating on making her more
intelligent
so that's pretty much it
a chill runs up your spine you feel like
you're being
watched so i get a druid option here
so this option you would get if you were
not a druid or if you were just to be a
fighter investigation
and so that is actually a very hard role
to make but if you're a druid you get a
nature option and that's a much
easier role to make and on top of that
unfortunately it's intelligence based
because it's nature but i do get plus
two from my proficiency in nature but i
get -1 from my intelligence which is
fairly low
luckily i got advantage on this role
because i use my enhanceability
and that means that i'm going to get to
roll twice should i fail
so most likely thanks to loaded dice
also i'm gonna make it because probably
i was unlucky before there you go i get
19 so that's a pretty good roll
and so i am now successful in this check
and something's going to happen stinking
and insidious assaults your senses
if you look around you see that it's not
such a nice sunlit
area it actually is a swamp and nothing
here is what it seems because for
instance if i'm going to click on this
this is why one of those little new
container uis that nick was
that david's talking about so if i click
on sorting options you get a bunch of
sorting options here if you click on
inventory you can access your inventory
and if i click on eat apple i get
an upset stomach and an upset stomach is
actually a form of poison
and i need to help myself now luckily
this is update 4 and we have protection
from poison
so i'm going to get rid of that poison
and on top of it i protect
my druid from further poisoning
by this evil swamp let's continue our
journey and see if we can find a
friendly soul
there's a guy with a red hat over there
so it's probably going to be nice
the red cap miguel is telling me that we
should be careful
right i'm probably gonna have a chat
with this guy and like ask him like
hello
uh do you know the way to i don't know
whiskey bar or something like that
the murderous glare of a red cap a fake
creature
known for its bloodlust greets you
that noise is the creature pretending to
be
a sheep so this guy
if i would have failed my role and not
have detected that this entire area as a
swamp
i would have seen us as a sheep and he
would be pretending that he's a sheep
i'll bite a weird sheep
however i have seen through the illusion
of the swamp so now i can see he's
actually a murderous red cap
and that he's pretending to be a sheep
now i can tell him like i know what
you're doing i can take the initiative
and surprise him by attacking him
or i can just say and since these are
dark times and it is good to be
optimistic in life we're going to say
and i would like the entire
stream to also say at the same time
because it just makes you smile
see we're going to do that again because
i'm pretty sure not everybody was into
it
so here goes his bar
again this creature doesn't realize
you can see its true form
and we're going to go all together now
on a baa i can't see the chat but i hope
you're buying like hell right now
there we go we get a good bar back and
doesn't that feel good
all right so these guys don't know that
we can see them so we're going to just
keep it that way and we're going to just
get closer
uh to the little old ladies shack
looks like the brothers didn't make it
let's go have a look at that
now remember what david was saying about
uh speak with that
gail happens to have an amulet and this
amoled gives them access to the speak
with death which is a level 3 necromancy
spell
and a level 3 is outside of range for my
level 4
wizard this is a complicated thing it is
a d d thing i have been nagging about it
for centuries
i've been told there's nothing that i
can do about this it will stay like this
forever
so we're trying to explain it to you
but i'm going to cast my level 3 spell
with my level 4 guy
using my amulet and this is going to
give me access to speak with that
and indeed as promised we get a
cinematic an updated cinematic
the course regards you lifelessly
and so i get to ask five questions so
we're gonna ask him first and foremost
if he find your sister
screaming but not
really uh
break the water
all right and i'm gonna just leave it at
that now david mentioned that we made it
more for a user friendly to be able to
continue
uh playing with speak with desk you
actually get to recast it on any dead
body
until i take a uh i think it's a long
rest so
i can now basically talk to his brother
and indeed we get another cinematic so
we see that that cinematic system
is now covered
and this is uh the method that we use
for when you kill everybody like a
an idiot and then you don't know what to
do anymore uh not that you're idiots of
course it's up to you how you play the
game and so forth
uh but if you kill everybody and uh you
didn't pay attention story you don't
know what to do anymore you can just go
talk to their bodies and then they'll
tell you what you have to do
so this guy is saying like well kill the
hack and that could give you a quest
update if you didn't get the quest etc
etc uh
so i'm gonna ask him what drove your
sister to leave she's scared
she won't be a good mom
but she will i
know it
[Applause]
[Music]
well we can agree on that uh let's ask
well i mean i think
well how did you die so
innocent
about why these brothers are dead what's
up with the sister
and what in general uh is going on with
swamp and the
gaps that are pretending to be sheep all
right
let's get in here and then you see the
decoration has also been if you played
it
in early access on day one and you play
now you see that everything is getting
continuously improved
but this place is starting to look
really nice all right let's go in here
i don't want a crumb left on that plate
girl
auntie ethel please one more bite and
this pie is gonna come back
up to say hello don't make me get the
wooden spoon
you're eating for two so get to it
if it isn't the cheekiest pop of them
all
you'd best have one hells of an apology
for me young man
uh i get a wizard option because i was i
had a girl selected so i'm going to tell
her
tell me hack is this intimidation part
of the bargaining process or does that
come
after oh the wizard thinks he's smart
because he can
read how many people do
you know i was gonna give you a swift
kick up the hours and show you the door
but i think you and i could have a bit
of fun together
god's grant me patience eat
up marina i won't
say it again oh if that is my arena
i have some bad news for her keep that
hole under your nose
shut things will get messy
you know what that sounds like to me
leverage
what is it what's going on
so now i get the option to say like
nothing i mistook you for someone else
or auntie attle killed your brothers
i'm going to tell her that auntie apple
killed her brothers that can't be true
auntie ethel they were being rude
and i detest rudeness
some time in the cage should do her good
and you you'll regret sticking your nose
in my
business
hello all right
so i think we're not gonna be friends so
we're gonna get in combat i'm gonna try
to show you a whole bunch of druid
powers in here
but don't ruin it so we got the hag over
here uh but we're also going to have to
deal with the red caps we're going to be
joining in a minute now there they are
so um i'm going to
use my druids ability uh
first of all and i'm going to cast it
at these two gentle fellows so basically
i now have a moon beam and every turn
my polar bear because i'm purple the
moon's root all right
okay perfectness and then i am going to
i don't have a bonus action i will wait
hold on i'm just going to use
switch the shadow hard now because she
is first in the turnover together with
the forward bear
then it's a whole bunch of the bad guys
and then it's going to be my fighter and
my word
so hard i'm going to cross
and so the blessed spell she needs to
stay concentrated on it but it gives a
1d4 bonus
to the attack roles and the saving throw
so it's basically going to give me a
higher chance to hit
at a higher chance to resist whatever
bad things they're going to throw at me
so i'm going to move shadow hard over
here i don't want to throw her in combat
she's my cleric
however you i want to throw in combat
but you
are blocked you're blocked because the
bear is bigger and he's blocked by my
fighter so that's a bit unfortunate
okay we'll just have to look at that
some poisonous fumes that's unfortunate
too
and she cast his vicious mockery uh
spell on it and what does that do
it gives me a disadvantage on my next
attack role so that's gonna be
compensated by my blessed spell
okay i'm going to give my it yankee she
has
a psionics ability which allows us to
jump apart
and i am going to teleport her next to
those guys
just to make sure uh that they don't
pass without my guitan
taking a swipe at her at them with her
her attack of opportunity
and then i'm going to use gail so i'm
first going to get him out of the poison
here
all right and i am going to
i'm going to cut oh no i'm going to do
grease first
somebody from the production team gave
me something to drink because of the
smoke behind me
i'm getting a very sore throat
all right so
we've got a whole bunch of um
uh greased up uh
what do you call them again the red caps
so i'm going to
try to well i'm going to smack at this
guy he's on the floor right
but she has i know sorry i need to
select my
my uh fighter and i'm going to use
accent search which actually
yeah i know i'm gonna do that uh all
right so i'm gonna just smack this guy i
should actually put them all on fire but
i like them being in degrees so i'm
gonna keep them in greece
just smack oh my god look at that 22.
that was pretty good
and he is gonna oh no he's fine why he's
not
exactly fine but he's gonna do well all
right
so my bear is poisoned but now it can
move
i'm gonna get him into combat so i'm
gonna give him a dash i'm ignoring the
hack because i know exactly what she's
going to be doing
she always does the same routine so i'm
going to go over there
i gotta warn you also there will be some
spoilers in this uh
and the bear and the guitar are
basically going to keep these guys away
and on the next turn i'm going to have i
hold the bear also although
my mouth is not reacting okay and i'm
going to do with her
i'm going to cross a guiding ball
again one of them
perfect that's 26 that must have killed
him wow
okay good all right hector stop
yes ah thank you sir
and they are doing
nasty things to my bear they're going to
try to kill my bear
hey you need to go away please okay
there she goes so she makes an
illusionary thing there and then she
dashes off
and then she's gonna leave it alone with
these guys we got to save my bear
all right there she goes uh so we got
another red cap
that's up oh my god not the bear ouch
so the bear is out of hp but now you see
how powerful the druid is actually
because
she just changed back into her druid
shape
and she still has she's still alive
which is actually a good thing okay and
we need to fix this here
now this guy has only 13 left this one
has 12
so if i do a really good sleep spell
like
sleep level two i can put two of them to
sleep bang there you go
and i only need to deal with this guy
and as it happens i got my get yankee
warrior here
uh she could boost herself so she's got
a really cool weapon actually
uh she's got this tears weapon sort of
justice it gives her tears protection so
she can boost her ac with two
which makes her very hard to hit but it
could also
spell her doom if she fails
so i gotta be careful and i already use
my action search what would you do
actually
you would you hit her or boost your
drink devotion or boost your ac
that's a big question yeah i know but i
have a bonus action will i drink
or will i use uh drink chug
okay i'll drink for plus 15 and then i'm
gonna just smack
oh that was not the best this max in the
world uh but maybe my wizard can still
do no he already moves right
okay well we'll just have to survive oh
that's great it's her turn
uh maybe we should remove some of the
poison on them
maybe we should add into the healing
that starts with my bars smart
pretty smart because these guys are
gonna wake up again eventually also
right
you have a scroll i think
all right nice one i need to need next
doors to her
all right well we're just going to try
to kill these guys then
that's oh my god i'm really really
really really
going well here this is going to be easy
this fight
and it's gone differently i can tell you
that um
all right we're gonna turn uh into a
uh arachnophobia warning we're going to
turn into a spider
and why am i going to turn into a spider
because i can oh no actually we're going
to do the deep rocky right
i'm going to go to the bull with the
fiery ice i'm just i'm going to ram him
alright there we go and we're just going
to ram these guys
run it oh that was a very disappointing
ramp
uh all right so you're still there
get a bit closer actually
you know i still have no i don't okay
you nerfed that
no worries up to them but this guy what
is he doing
he's casting bloodlust on this guy what
does bloodlust do
probably nothing good oh oh he can hit
three times
that's a multi-attack uh it's because of
the bloodlust right
creature can attack three times it
regains 3d6 hit points if it lands a
killing load
we can't allow that to happen all right
so 22
[Music]
i'm going to put my ac up
all right so that's going to give me
like a very high uh armor class now 18
so
15 from armor plus one from dexterity
plus two from the boost
and we're going to smack this guy
oh this is a good smack and now okay he
can finish her he can probably finish it
off with his magic missiles
uh so let's try that
gas magic missile or actually oh no
let's go oh
no yeah
goodbye there you go very very very good
unfortunately there's a level cap so i'm
not really leveling we would still put
the level cap in early access to
level uh four uh but we're doing not
that bad actually
it's gonna work out so if she knows
him maybe
all right got one guy left
what can't go wrong nothing i guess all
right i'm actually quite proud of this
this is going really well
but i was lucky in my dice i think all
right or maybe it was below the dice
that were to my advantage
i shoot this guy i know do you still
have your jump your mega jump you do
right
so jump do your mega jump next to him
boom
didn't expect that did you red cap and
boom boom boom
all right no boom uh okay let's try that
again
oh well this is an excellent opportunity
to bring
my flaming sphere why is my flaming
sphere not clicking
okay so can you get close enough yeah
i can i can get there no there okay
so now he's not only having to deal with
a dangerous get yankee
he also has to deal with a dangerous
flaming ball of fire
this is going really well
all right so let's see um
can i do the tournament just to please
nick if he likes it that spell so much
no i'm gonna do the moon
maybe i'll throw a good bear and
nobody's gonna throw a good barrier
right and so from now on i'm going to
follow him with the move
with the moon beam so that should work
out well
and she is going to finish it off she's
going to use her overpowered guiding
balls
too all right can you get closer no you
can't dash right
so i'm gonna make her dash gives her
extra movement
and i'm gonna get closer so that the
next turn i can hit him
all right i think this fight is at an
end oh
that is because of my armor that's so
good
ninety percent loaded dies baby that's
not a miss
and ninety percent unfortunate the ball
can hit him
all right wall you actually have a ram
attack
so ram ramen at 50 percent
good well not terribly exciting the 50
but okay this is a this is a dumb fight
you're out of okay
let's do that
i got all the smoke in my face it's not
working well
uh all right let's do the witch ball
and that should do
her in all right oh [ __ ] my druid is
down
all right well let's um we're going to
resurrect when she's not that i need to
help her oh my god we're really not good
oh now she's dead all right we're gonna
need a resurrection scroll and then
we're gonna need to go and rest in camp
because things could have
been going better all right
so can we oh my god
oh that could have gone better okay so
let's
uh guys could we switch up the smoke
behind me because
i can hardly breathe um okay
so let's uh
do the scroll of revivify
and oh i'm just let's
do it vice versa let's put this up here
and then put this one and then we're
going to bring back
with that click on party more important
uh trick
that david's oh it doesn't work for
resurrect please tell me it works very
strict
it doesn't work for restrict yet oh no
that's a bug
okay well then we'll just do it here
things happen
all right good so uh we still have gail
that's dead so we're gonna have to
sacrifice yet another one of these
scrolls of resurrection
and they're expensive so i'm gonna have
to buy new ones
and we gotta find gailbeck uh who is
down here
and uh we are going to
he's stable i think i think he should
have yeah he's uh he needs he just needs
help
yeah that's right he has the argument of
type stabilization but i can't select
him it looks like
uh oh i'm gonna get in trouble here
gail i just should click on your icon
there oh so that does work
clicking on the party i have a problem
with my mouse here so i might be
actually misclicking so
apologies for it it has to do with the
armor uh
all right we gotta go to camp end my day
and uh just have a little rest here
so we're gonna get a small moment with
shadowheart i guess
dancing it has to open surely
has to do something shadowheart's
attention is consumed by a strange box
that she turns over in her hands the box
is inscribed with glyphs
similar to those used by the githyanki
all right my arcana check was successful
so a git yankee artifact how did you
come by that instant
shadow heart hides the box from view
keep out of it uh okay i know what she's
gonna do i mean like if i ask any of
these questions she's gonna be angry at
me but i mean she's angry at me anyway
so
uh no need to be secretive statement if
not an accurate one
leave me be i'm shadowheart so many
secrets
all right uh well let's see if we can
find a friend here so how about the dog
is this scratch the dog pants
and he's got a ball in his mouth
all right let's see if i can wrestle it
from him
just not i do have inspiration for it so
i could try again but i'm not going to
do that instead
i'm going to do a little trick that i
discovered
and that is uh i'm going to let him keep
the ball
but i'm going to use oh i'm i need a
little short rest here
uh so that i get these wide shape points
back so i have two charges
and the short rest restores them uh i'm
going to turn myself
into a wolf
then i'm gonna alpha the dog because
it's cat's day it's not
dog day the dog holds a well chewed ball
in his mouth
all right and now i'm all fighting him
i'm basically telling him
hand over the ball and so as these
things go
i'm not even gonna argue all right it's
only fair that you enjoy it too
but if you feel like throwing it i
wouldn't mind that at all
i didn't introduce myself before you can
call me scratch
ah man you're a nice dog okay i'm sorry
i'm sorry about what happened to your
owner so i found this dog
near his master who was killed and so i
adopted him
and now i'm all fighting him and now i
feel bad about it but
all right so oh
i stayed with him until until i knew he
was gone
no one can replace him i'm going to have
somewhere to lay my head
all right okay dog all right
i guess oh no we need to get and uh we
need to find
some new resurrection things because in
case it goes wrong
so let's go there and where is it hello
oh can't speak like that so let me
dismiss my wild shape
and let's talk so the way it works if
you talk to your companions you can
actually talk when you're an animal
because they know about you
if you talk with strangers you do need
to turn yourself into
your regular form thy name has been
recorded
but this guy i picked him up in a song
chapel
later in the game uh and uh but the cool
part about him is that he
actually because it is not
by choice self-restriction scrolls
all right so amending of the threads
between life
and death should thou or any of thy
compatriots perish
i will cleave soul to body once more
okay what's the cost a matter of coin
that's outrageous such is life
outrage leading to a singular
end isn't that right
okay well you know what i'm going to
trade you for some restrictions cross
and i'm going to buy all of them and i'm
going to give
you for that i'm going to give you the
dog's ball no i'm going to
not going to do that right i'm just
going to buy them all right
okay all right oh no i did it wrong
no no no all right
well that is that is the way it goes i
misclicked oh no
[Music]
no restriction scrolls this is going to
be great how much money do i have
nothing i have what two scrolls left
three scrolls left all right well we
should be able to handle it i think i'll
better go to sleep right
rather than pulling around here and
continue my exploration of the druids
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
try uh our druid shape
and we're gonna go into the dungeon of
the hack and we're going to try to
solo the dungeon and save
uh my arena from the hack using nothing
but my druid abilities
and without getting the rest of the
party involved if you get into combat
with the hack
there might be a need to call them in
because that would be a little bit hard
but i think i can manage to do a lot of
this dungeon just
using my druid all right so i'm gonna
pick my druids i'm gonna disconnect her
from the party
oh wait however i am going to get a
little bit of help i'm going to ask
shadowheart here
uh to give me a blessing and the
blessing that she needs to give me
is uh protection against evil because
good and evil actually so the way that
works is
actually get good and evil uh gives you
a creature protection against
aberrations celestia's elementals
but especially fey and phase what that
hack is
and that's gonna prevent her from
charming frightening or possessing me
things that she's actually particularly
good at
all right so let's take shadow hearts
yeah
this mouse is blocking me uh
and um all right
and then let's cast protection from evil
and good
does it make a difference if i do it
level one and two i don't think it makes
a difference right so i'll just keep the
level one
okay good uh so she needs to keep on
concentrating on this so she can't give
me anything else can she give me
actually she can't protect me from
poison also
that doesn't require concentration all
right so consider me buffed off and can
i actually get the shield or is that
only
that's only for myself right uh okay
so anything else or you can give me
false life i guess
is false life going to maintain i know
it's only for yourself okay never mind
all right consider my druid buff and let
her enter
the dungeon oh no that's not you the
druid i said
better let's see what's going to happen
to us
this would be i'm going to just live
dangerously
all right let's first go and introduce
ourselves
to the locals they have anything to say
with us
all right this looks like a pleasant
place
this is my personal playhouse
and you don't have an invite get
out all right well you know what i think
i'll stay a while
leave oh you'll end up in tonight's stew
we'll go nicely with marina she's
already
mad oh that's a writer being clever
there
all right so this is like a small mosul
a museum of the hacks trophies uh so
here you see a woman that's holding her
own head and if you click on the
wished for the hat of a genius
there's a guy trapped in the in the
mirror uh
we're looking for uh on this guy uh well
actually we can listen to his story my
dearest efren
he begged me to hold the deadly disease
that
ravaged him
alright so a whole bunch of victims of
the hack here so
to convince us that she's not a very
nice person so
and here is actually a trick this is why
i actually took the protection against
good and evil because i knew i was going
to come here
so this mask if you put it on
you become part of the flock and let us
just do that so you can see what happens
so let me equip it
the mask suits you just relax
and so if i wouldn't have my protection
against evil and good
what would have happened now is that
every turn so that's basically every six
seconds
i would have to roll a wisdom throw and
or risk being controlled by the hag and
if i were controlled by the hack my
party would lose me
uh which leads to lots of hilarity and
multiplayer obviously
i'm sorry wrong button uh now
putting on the mask actually does have
its advantages because it allows me to
see the illusions of the hack
and so we notice that this door is an
illusion and so what i can do is i can
just
walk through this door are obviously
other ways of discovering this but this
is a particularly neat way of doing it
all right remember what nick said about
the utility value of a cat
we're going to assume what chip cat now
okay so we're going to use the cat to
bypass these nuts oh actually no
man okay it's too late right
okay i'm going to i'm going to change
this i'm going to dismiss my white shirt
so the thing is that i i still have that
mask effect on me and i want i don't
want them
uh where is it okay so i'm just gonna
drop this on the floor because it's
useless now
and i'm going to make a short rest
because i'm gonna have to change
something okay so
let me do that again let me turn into a
cat
so you see now these guys are my enemies
and that's because i don't have the mask
on anymore because if i have the mouse
they would consider me one of them
uh now what we're going to do is we want
to get
over here to this waterfall but there
are nasties walking around here
patrolling around
now the cat is an excellent stealth form
if you look at the stats of the cat
and you go to its dexterity then you see
that it gets a plus four to itself which
is
really really good now if we go into
style move stealth mode so now the cat
is in stealth mode
you see uh vision cones that appear so
vision cones like this these red ones if
i walk into that i need to make a roll
and this roll
is going to depend on my stealth value
so i have a pretty good chance of
succeeding in this
but i just want to make sure so i'm
going to try to avoid getting into this
area
you see that little circle that little
sun on my cursor
now it's currently hollow and here it's
full here it's because this is a
zone where there's light so if i go
there it's going to be harder to remain
and stealth and here it's
easier because it it's hollow so i'm
going to try to get up there and
to make it easier for me to control the
game i'm going to hit the enter turn
based mode
and so essentially i am now playing
doing this turn by turn it allows me for
pinpoint accuracy so if i click
on the jump button now i'm going to be
able to jump on this thing
and so and then it's going to be the end
of my turn you see i could actually
position myself there where the guy
can't see me and then i'm going to end
my turn
now it's up to the bad guys and so they
get their turn so when they finish
moving it's going to be my turn again
and so we got a guy here that is very
close so we're going to just skip our
turn just let him pause by
all right and do a little inspection of
this guy
so if we examine him we notice that he
is a human
now it doesn't show here yet it's one of
the things that we need to add still
but the humans don't have dark vision so
they can't see in the dark uh if we go
over here for instance these guys
so let's have a look at this guy here
this guy
is a draw half elf notoriously good at
seeing in the dark
so what i'm going to do is i'm now going
to sneak off this ladder in my cat form
let's make sneak snake all right and i'm
going to switch up blue
switch up the light all right i'm gonna
stand here and just hope he's not gonna
see me i
i actually went down a little bit all
right so let's see what's gonna happen
it's their turn and see he can't see
anymore because it's dark so his vision
is affected by this
so this was a really good move and do
you know what is a very very stupid move
like the most stupid thing that you
could do right now
it's like hitting the meow but so we're
going to do that all right
and so the meow button obviously alerts
them
these guys are surprised because they
didn't expect a sneaking cat to be
here in the dark and so they are now
all active and hostile to me and so each
turn these guys are going to be rolling
for wisdom and if they fail they're
going to be hostile and attack me and if
they succeed they'll try they're going
to try to resist the hack that's in
their heads
now look at my cat who became very
ferocious on international cat day
uh we're not going to kill our cat by
attacking so instead what we're going to
do is
we're going to use that dismissed wild
shape here so we're going to turn
ourselves
into a bird all right
okay a diorama to be precise
and so we're going to use the ability of
the diary to
fly so to get ourselves out of this area
all right i'm gonna fly over there look
at that good bird go
and the bird has incredible mobility on
the battlefield right so
we're going to try to we can actually
make this one
but these guys are never going to catch
up with us so it's an excellent flea
uh creature look at it it can still keep
on going actually
can it make this one oh yes it can look
at it go look at it go whoo
there you go so it managed oh and
there's traps here
and it actually managed to fly out of
combat so i can now leave turn based
mode
uh i don't know sorry i don't want to
flee uh i'm actually outside i know i'm
still in turn i'm sorry
it's just not far enough yet so these
guys don't know where to go
now i'm gonna just jump out of combat
i'm gonna get
head over here can i yeah i can
look at that and now i'm out of combat
all right
and so i'm going to get out of my white
shape for a form here
so see all the things that i'm doing i'm
just using my druid form i haven't
actually engaged in combat at all yet
i just used my utility shapes to be able
to get here
and now i'm going to take a short rest
my last shortcut
and i'm going to turn myself into a
badger we learned from nick that the
badger form is
excellent at sneaking all right
and look what we have over there well
not excellent sneaking excellent that
portaling
teleporting itself we're gonna badger up
over here
and that's not working sorry and
i'm gonna say hey marina marina
can you hear me she can't hear me
because i'm sneaking so i'm just going
to get out of sneak for
unfortunately i forgot to do something
you come to my home
all right
being an animal using all of the animals
abilities
and do it all over again
stop it please let me go
she she actually doesn't deserve to be
safe for the overacting but
what's she doing she's putting the cage
on fire
and then what she's got initiative on me
on top of it
oh yeah she's summoning a bunch of the
most guys
okay and marina can't do a lot because
she's in her cage
and then it's me the hero of the story
so this cage this cage
because i was surprised i didn't get a
move right oh man
it got even worse now there's illusions
of the hack here also
oh man so this cage is on fire
18 out of 40. and i can badger myself
closer to her
but i don't have a i don't have a speed
potion which i was supposed to pick up
which i forgot
because i was all right we're gonna have
to bring in the cavalry so
there goes the bet so oh the team has
been betting on me
failing this i hate it when they're
right
all right um but it's not over yet uh
we're gonna bring in
we're gonna try to do this with as
minimum cavalry as possible right so
we're gonna bring in the wizard
and the wizard for good reasons uh first
of all the wizard is gonna actually go
and pick up
uh let's see what you have you have a
potion of animal speaking
and healing we're gonna need those uh
what is over there
this is the potion of greater healing
this is even better
i think i need to go up here to be able
to pick up the rest
so you go up oops yeah camera work is
something that is still in progress so
what is this oh yeah there you go uh so
it is going to improve
um click on this once a bit of gold
actually if i were to have 200 gold i
would be able to go and buy at least one
of those restrictions scrolls back
let's pick up this portion of greater
healing two but i need
a potion of speed and i know there's one
here in the in the house of the hack
i think it's over there all right this
is the one we needed the potion of speed
portion of invisibility potion of
healing i wonder
well we're gonna try this right we're
gonna just try it
okay so we're gonna do this uh without
glitching it
completely so we're gonna go down
and we're gonna head over here
so we're gonna go inside of the cave
continue our journey and now we don't
have to worry anymore about
those mast avengers i was gonna say
those musk guys
because uh they are all gone because
they were summed by the hack so we can
just get through this area
the only thing we'll need to deal with
is
the uh poison cloud now i've been in
this situation before for other reasons
so that's why i know pretty much how i'm
going to handle this
and i as i was experimenting with the
game i found a
a pretty cool systemic i want to show it
to you
i'm gonna jump over here you see these
poison clouds they're really not good
for me they're not healthy
but what i can do is i can summon my
ball of fire
and so the cool part about my ball of
fire
is that it's heavy all right and so
because it's heavy
it basically can destroy the traps by
just rolling over them and so that is
just insanely cool
right i just have to be careful because
it can also burn the ladders
uh so that's a problem uh but otherwise
i'll
just destroy the ladder uh but like this
it is actually a uh see i can just i
just need to be able to navigate it
because it is fairly large
i'm gonna get myself stuck here oh god
i'm gonna get myself stuck did i get
myself stuck with my bowl
i did get myself a second michael over
here bull
how did i do this uh am i going the
wrong way i'm doing the wrong way i
guess
okay ball do something
ah i thought i could get through here i
did get through before
nope and this is a bit cynically seen
still
it's all part of the game in my in
production
and i actually don't remember just being
a blocker over here
so can i no no no i'm not gonna be able
to use
my super super super trick unless i can
enhance the jump
can i enhance the jump of my wall with
my wizard
i don't think so oh man okay well then
we're gonna get him closer here you can
shove it
i can shove the ball you can shove the
ball
or your standard wave on it yeah i need
to make sure that i don't have my wizard
killed by the time i get there
so let me try all right ball
i need you to do your thing well i need
you to help me
all right oh look at the ball go
whoo-hoo
all right that's more like it ball all
right i could have done better with my
first ball
it did cost me a spell slot right and
my guy is not super healthy either okay
is there any way nick that i can make
him like hard to see
like with blur no that doesn't help it
anyway
i think you got a portion of
invisibility isn't it the white one
that's the speed one no no the other one
uh on the first part oh i wasn't super
lucky
okay good all right let's approach ball
yeah with the position of invisibility
you're going to be able to bring my
potion of speed
to uh
my badger and this should do what i
needed to do
all right i do need uh i'm gonna take a
healing potion here because
otherwise i don't want to be dead so we
have this really uh
interesting cool system where uh combat
and turn based you can basically jump
away from it and continue playing in
real time then have your other party
members join
it is not a thing that if you think
about it as it's super logical the
multiplayer works really well
and and single player it actually aids
you in combat when you're
in pickles like this so um
i'm gonna start sneaking
all right all i need to do is get to him
and i could actually use my magic
pockets to get it to him it's a much
more fun if i do it this way right
so if i'm invisible and i get to him i'm
good right
yeah that's gonna be quick you need to
act
oh yeah ha but after this move can also
throw the potion
i could but if i miss he's not gonna be
invisible
actually
he's invisible now right i gave it to
him all right so he's invisible
so he could technically speaking get to
the hack and try to throw her
into the cousin
all right well let's do these things uh
you need
to well yeah do we consider him to be
close enough
we do right to pass the potion should we
yeah you want me to throw it i'm 85
percent sure this is gonna work you're
85
but if it fails we're going to be dead
all right let's use the the conventional
way which is to pass through the potion
all right so let's glitch our own system
all right
do it like this so that my batter can
now oh what did i do sorry um
can burrow himself over there
i'm going to do a bar over here okay
so this is good but over there
and now i'm going to drink that potion
this is why this potion was so important
to me
i needed that portion of speed because
it gives me an extra action actually i
should have used it before because i
might
not get there i don't have the range
oh yes can i i can i can
nick you know what this means
marina is safe marina is safe exactly
all right so let me click that
there she goes she was in the pickle
because if she would have fallen if that
thing would have burned she would have
fallen there
she would have been dead all right this
was pretty pretty good
okay all right so let's press
and turn and see what happens
okay so and let's turn on you he's
actually in uh
he's protected from evil see that
protection from evil
help there i think
that's
what happened to my protection
oh my god
looks like an easy fight
the game that's what the hag wanted you
to think
oh man everything's an illusion right oh
man come on
i'm still alive though i'm not dead yet
are the druids don't hit me don't hit me
please don't hit me i can make it as a
druid
don't don't don't hit marina yes i can
see that hag never lose
all right
those voices are not recorded yet so
that's what that exclamation mark means
oh man
where's gail when you need him anyway
all right what do you think nick missy
steph
is going to break my invisibility missed
a step here
oh you know what i'm going to do thunder
wave
all right baby you can do it son
ah no no no no i just need to i need to
move a little bit or
more behind her okay
i'm gonna actually manage to do this and
like i will be the victor of the day
check this out
check this out check it out all right
it dies
saving throw she's very athletic for a
hack
all right this is not gonna work out is
it um
best laid plan of men and mice all right
let's make this more interesting for
ourselves let's turn into the bear
i'm pretty sure if i were to throw i
just need to know which one it is but
that
he could actually help me with this
right uh
you think i need the others
it looks like it certainly looks like it
right so okay we're going to try to get
the others in here
all right this is this might be a little
bit more of an epic battle than we
expected
it was going to be okay so you think
he's going to be able to get through
oh he's got he can dash twice because of
the thing
the potion of the person yeah look at
that
no leave me alone so he's gonna be able
to dash all the way to the summoning
ring oh this is cool
okay so there open the door
stick there i gotta say so i knew this
game a little bit
uh so i know that there is an actual
ring here
and so through this ring i will be able
to bring in
the rest of the party to help us the
meantime i need to make sure that this
guy is not dead
god he's gonna die
oh it's your turn no i just sorry
come on guys i mean you gotta put your
heart in it you gotta resist a little
bit
i'm never gonna make it this right
probably way over the schedule already
uh gotta respect the hag
i am i'm much more respectful already
but he drove me to try this life
hybris like it's always the beginning of
the end
he's just standing there well i'm
[Applause]
like
what do you think no
it's not going to work right
oh he's dead all right well i guess i
can get the cavalry ready
uh let's see let's get them outside oh
actually they don't need to go outside
again or
actually they should get close to this
door here
over there i guess or is it i think
that's the way right and so
where's the bear they're still suffering
it's almost there
she's starting to heal everybody
so yeah so we did start the stream by
saying you shouldn't try this at home
now you see why
just if that thunder wave would have
worked
ah my plan was almost foolproof i
trusted the loaded dice
i'm out of movement i gotta dash again
i really shouldn't have done the bear
but yeah he has a high survivability so
that's what i want to do
okay so the bear is good
i'm going to send these guys over here
uh
what's blocking them at the door is uh
preventing them from getting it
can i look pick this door i don't have
any lock picks all right so let's just
smack it then
uh smack it off look at the sword man
boom okay can you please go
and hate your friend who's down there
so this could be perfectly a situation
multiplayer where an idiot like me would
have gone down
all on his own and then take his friends
to come and help him
the bear is not in a good shape though
guys no he's dead right so i can't short
rest if they're that right
won't be able to do that okay oh man
oh man oh man all right shadow heart can
you do something about this
well she should have some healing spells
on her uh in the first place i think uh
she has a scroll i think she has do you
think i i will
leave it just on the scrolls like in
combat
no it's better to get one yeah yeah i
think so i'm going to remove the
enhanced ability
healing word sure yeah
what about the other one the um left
and button hey what do you want me to do
pure ones
no killing or this one yeah you think
i'm fine
all right so
i'm not going to waste a thing on him he
needs to
he actually has a lunar mint which you
can use
but i probably should i should probably
do healing words right
uh can i throw a like a healing potion
at him yeah
and that works yep all right let's do
that potion of greater healing
throw it in see how this works
all right okay something else we're
fixing for this patch actually
is that potions don't deal damage
hopefully
it didn't do that it didn't deal damage
yeah damage right if i did that yeah
because of course it's physics you throw
a bottle with someone but yeah we see
people
keep killing their companions with that
and we want to try typically when you
throw a potion it is because you're in
trouble just like i am yes all right so
it's three of us
and one potential extra ally against a
bunch of really nasty people hey
actually wait a minute
we're here in her thing or she's got a
whole bunch of rings so let's take all
of those
uh what else do we have here uh i know
there's a potion somewhere here
the portion of speed there's another
portion of speed here so let's take that
one
uh stuff of chromes we're not going to
take just yet there's a whole bunch of
nasty surprises here which we don't want
either
okay nick you got any strategies that
you think i should use
in trying to get my body back and
especially kill the hack
i think if i can manage to get to the
hack and throw her into the cousin
and that is a successful role that is
that is she dying
oh she's necros gayle is killing her
you should shove gail at that time this
guy keeps on healing her i mean
i think he's cheating because he can
keep on healing her so it's like gail
versus marina
oh my god look at that okay so i gotta
explain this to the players that are
watching
uh when he dies has necrosis around him
and so this is now being used against
these guys
maybe this is actually pretty good so
that means the hack is all on their own
i think actually my best chances would
actually be to go into cat and then
pusher
badger you can try yeah i know that i
can try but do you think they have any
chances of success
um low one she is she is very strong
and heavy even for a badger
even for a badger all right uh i think i
should try
or you think i should i shouldn't try
well for the stream
with a psionics jump sure no no
do you have a pushing ability on your
iphone key i do i have soft oh you have
i have thunder wave
oh well with bonus action shot maybe i
can get there right
all right let's try to get yankee who
needs a druid right
do you know which one is the real one no
but i think there's only one right now
i think her other forms are gone for the
moment so i think this is
actually her she'll probably
someone more so you need a good
initiative for all here
i need a good initiative role right well
i'm blessed right so oh you can surprise
her with a with a
arrow with a bow attack so if i surprise
her with a bow attack can i then still
jump behind her so i can jump
to throw her off yeah you should get a
new new turn so
is that a good a hail of turns is that
good opening attack
ah you sure it's 35
35 but this is 45
i can also throw my boots you know i've
had great success with it in the past
it's 45
do you think i can make this well you're
you're attacking for the sake of the
first turn
yes so what do you want me to do attack
let's go for it
all right i'm not going to do 35
actually i'm going to pinner
45
oh it worked so that actually slows her
right yeah
okay great oh this is good yeah and she
skipped her turn so
um now we need to do our thing i should
have done the thing before i have an
action search
so i need to take that potion of speed
that we found where is it
okay give it to her
okay so she got the potion of speed
which allows me to get
and next to her ouch yeah that cost your
bonus action
what why didn't you say anything i do
have i have thunder rife
all right all right what do you think
you need to aim it so it's blue
yes this right no not good
wait a minute this works normally yeah
it's a little tricky
to get the ah there it is ah this is a
bit frankly tail
i can see there's a there's an angle
okay all right you ready all right
close your eyes how you think i'm afraid
now
because if i fail it's probably gonna be
game over right
well let's let's set all of the dice
all right uh do it again all right do it
again do it again
you think it's going to work well you
keep it rolling nice of course
the loaded dice need to kick in
any time now yes
oh no she's on the other side
that's a hack for you you thought you
got her
i know nope
no oh and he has what he has no watch f
sharks left
can he push her yeah it's a badger
yeah he's not a badger he doesn't have
wide shape charges anymore oh yeah
he can sneak into the combat right so he
can get behind her
look at that bear go man
all right so i'm gonna dismiss my white
shape where is it
the smith white shape
i can't see the stream so i'm probably
boring people by now by doing all these
things but
all right oh she doesn't have a potion
of speed anymore damn it
i wanted to push her with a bonus action
that wouldn't have even helped
don't have anything clever that i can do
not really
uh okay well not making a terrible
impression here am i
are you impressed nick i'm impressed
with the hag
you're impressed with the tenacity well
you know i can i could put on the torch
i'm not going to use the accent this is
going very well during rehearsals you
know
i know i don't know i know this was
going very well during rush yeah
but we've been plagued by a whole bunch
of problems right so
uh no oh yeah
oh there's no way we're gonna make it
now i need to figure out where she is
where's gail actually
from the other side all right so there
you go
right here actually i could probably
resurrect him there from these guys
so if i use my last resurrection scroll
and i try to get the girl i'm going to
get this closer
all right so i should probably put that
on my bar here now you know why i wanted
to buy the resurrection scrolls
i did say i was gonna try glitching
things uh let's
teleport them to a safe spot oh yeah
that's a good that's a good statement
all right hi and mighty right next to
the enemy arch
yeah but she's gonna you're gonna see
she's gonna have a successful attack
role
and that's gonna be good and then we're
going to okay
so you still need to
shoot at one of those so that we can
actually we need to figure out which one
is a real hack so if i shoot her
with my 20 chance to hit ah
man okay i bet i can move oh no
i could make some good berries
maybe moon beams get spikes actually on
these
there you go
why are they not hit by the spikes well
they're slowed down so if they
happen to move slow down
if they happen to move they'll be in
there all right maybe i could uh man
keep on people making the bad decisions
here
all right i can actually smack this guy
right but i don't want to kill them
really i just want to uh
do something useful oh yeah
he's not in battle bring her in the
battle
god i wish i could see the stream
telling me what i need to do
i would have done exactly that and then
i could blame them for it
uh where's she going what's she doing
oh yeah all right so we're probably not
going to make it
instead no save games ah
i'm gonna die i'm gonna die i'm gonna
die so hard
if only i could just push her into the
bloody thing if my plan had worked
if only if only if only try to pull her
down
with uh druid i don't know my dad drew
it
oh yeah yeah that that one right so
i need to get to her first to help her
can i make that jump
i can all right so give her a helping
hand
open hands stand up
if i win this fight
i shall be very happy
all right i know i don't think so i
don't think this is a good idea don't i
throw something like
really hard at her like a a long sword
or i can block great axe would that hurt
her probably not
a little can i reach herself i can
actually
alright that was a fake one great
i guess it's progress
there's no way i'm going to make this
video
an anti-climax
i don't know so now you know what you're
not going to be
i think marina is not going to make it
either
[Music]
who's actually still standing
shadowheart i might do it with 1 out of
31.
okay yes that's what i want to see from
you
so we got shadowheart left
i think this is gonna be it i think this
is where we
we have to adjust the seat is the hack
going to prevail
the hack will prevail secretly people
say that against me
uh are gonna be correct it's shadow hard
she's what
she's described
all right well that did not go exactly
as we had
expected uh but such as the nature of uh
live gameplay
so one thing our production team wants
us to remind the viewers
is when the patch is gonna come out yeah
that's right actually we should mention
this
uh so patch four is still currently
still in qa we had hoped it was going to
be ready this week
but we found some uh nagging bugs that
we wanted to absolutely fix
before we gave it to you so we're
waiting actually from word from our qa
when it's ready
we expect it's going to be next week we
don't know exactly when next week
but once we have that we will be sure to
announce it on our channel so a little
bit more patience
you could see glimpses of the druid
gameplay here because i didn't do it as
well as i had hoped that was going to do
it
but there's a lot of cool stuff to
explore with it when you try it out
now need to mention uh this is still
early access so only get into it if you
are interested in how a game evolves
during early access otherwise
wait for the full game to be there uh
but yeah i think that you can see
it is evolving and there's a lot of the
druid class actually does add a lot of
gameplay had a lot of fun fooling around
with it
uh i can actually win this fight um if
the loader dies are on my side
i saw that it happened
so uh thank you for watching
uh thank you for supporting us uh on
early access as always
let us know your thoughts uh we are
reading we are listening
uh we're very curious to see how you
guys are going to abuse or use
the druid and your parties and
multiplayer and single player
very very curious about what you're
going to think about the new update
so it's going to your way soon we will
be obviously continuing development we
still have a long journey ahead of us
there's gonna be many updates uh but bit
by bit we're gonna get there and maybe
g3 the game that it deserves to be
uh with all of that said i wanna thank
everybody involved in preparing this
this was not the easiest thing to set up
uh in the corona circumstances but we
managed nonetheless
uh thank you everybody here on the panel
also for joining me
and uh being so cool and uh thank you
for
uh watching so uh we're gonna dash off
with a
uh a trailer that shows the droot and
all of its shapes
and then it's going to be until next
time on the next
update or on the next panel from hell
take care everybody bye bye cheers
an army was coming she said goblins
drow and more still legions upon legions
the druids of cloakwood knew the dangers
this would bring
there was but one droid who guarded the
circle
[Music]
who protected our ways
[Music]
hmm
you burn like fire you howl like wind
you are faith warden
[Music]
go forth and let your might
be known
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you